sind wir es auch leid immer ihre sachen
in den händen tragen zu müssen dann
holen sie sich jetzt die neue imac ja
eine plastiktüte mit apple-logo vorne
drauf hallo leute mal wenn ich hier und
ich möchte euch mit diesem video sagen
dass mein leben gerade ein einziger
scherbenhaufen ist und alles schief was
schief laufen kann
ich war am wochenende in kiel und habe
auch der vater ein neues video
geschnitten als mein laptop plötzlich
den geist aufgegeben hat er ist danach
nicht mehr angegangen warum ich mir
heute auch einen neuen laptop gekauft
habe für sehr sehr viel geld und jetzt
fragst du dich gerade warum ich dieses
video hier mache ich weiß auch nicht so
genau
ich habe gerade einfach nur das gefühl
und sagen zu müssen dass ich eine riesen
pechsträhne hab ich drehe videos wo der
ton nicht richtig funktioniert ich drehe
videos so dass bild irgendwann nicht
richtig da ist oder mein letztes nicht
schneiden konnte jetzt hoffe ich dass
ich mit dem neuen laptop und bald
vielleicht auch mit einem richtig coolen
schnitt pc und einer kamera und licht
und so dass ich ein bald wieder ganz
tolle videos machen kann von zu hause
aus und nicht mehr immer auf andere
angewiesen bin
aber bis dahin gibt es bei mir nicht so
richtig alltag und ich bin immer noch am
umziehen und meinen kopf platzt mir bald
ein bisschen aber ich hoffe dass ihr
verständnis hat ja das möchte ich möchte
betreuer verständnis beten bitten und
euch sagen bei wieder alles so wie
früher und ich hoffe dieses bald kommt
ganz bald
ich wünsche euch eine traumhafte woche
und noch immer den kopf nicht in den
sand hängen lassen
es ist wie es ist es ist nicht immer
alle tempi und wir sind keine maschinen
wir sind menschen manchmal passiert
zeigt ja aber mehr kann ich auch nicht
sagen
wir sehen uns dann ganz bald wieder wenn
ich das neue video geschnitten habe und
zu ganz vielen anderen sachen babyspeck
wann wird wissen kommt alles kommt alles
passt ich will hier auch wirklich werte
trainieren das ist thema morgen
trainieren als kreativer mensch der
eigentlich sachen machen möchte
plötzlich so riedl
zu haben die einem irgendwie tore
verschließen zu dem was man machen
möchte
ihr merkt mir fehlen einfach die worte
ich hoffe es ist bald wieder alles gut
ja gut damit zum nächsten mal